i think you liked him too much i didn't
like him too much he's just that
[ __ ] i don't like him you want
to act like you don't but there was
moments in that where i was just like oh
he doesn't hate him yeah this time i
didn't have that static like i did he's
likeable yeah he's like he's a cool guy
he's a cool guy he's a cool guy
in different weight divisions you could
probably root for him yeah definitely i
did even when he was fighting for the
middleweight title
um against uh romero for the vacant
title i was rooting for him because i
wanted oceania to have a belt yeah have
a champion yeah and i even said in the
media on the press conference i said
like what he's done from tough nationals
to the to the middleweight belt was
amazing from outside of the world he was
one of the first to do it so i was like
yo we can do this i already knew we
could do it but for him to do it i was
like yo we you know we really got one of
us in a sense there was a moment where i
was watching the first round you were
just super dumb in the first round i was
on and and i was a moment where i was
like don't take your [ __ ] foot off
the gas because there was a moment where
you were just landing kicks you were
just chewing up that leg yeah and i was
just like oh i hope that he doesn't just
cruise yeah
because when you hate a [ __ ]
they go bald
yeah
right lose their hair violate them truly
yeah in the worst way possible yeah but
um after the first round i one thing i
wish i had done was ask eugene
what what dropped him because it felt
like nothing to me like and i didn't
even know what stance i was on because
you know i'm not really like actively
thinking
um it's just muscle memory and instinct
and i wish because the first time i
fought him right
straight left right yeah straight left
on the pipes
but i didn't know at the time and the
first time i fought him we pretty much i
caught an audible i was in the in the
cage and i just felt like you know what
i'm gonna match this guy's intensity and
i did and i was just feeling myself
feeling my instincts
i wish i'd done that a bit more this
fight there was a time maybe in the
second round i was like man i'm i'm
feeling better southpaw but i was like
let's stick to the game plan like eugene
said i wish i'd called an autoboy and
just stuck more southpaw because i was
fine i was finding southpaw he couldn't
touch me yeah and
yeah that straight left was landing and
i could have changed that up a bit and
the kicks as well that inside leg yes
exactly yeah but i wish i trusted my
instinct more but i was like you know
what last time we just i had a great
result last time when i followed my
instincts so i wish i'd done that now
but i'm gonna watch the fight again and
and really like soak it in but right now
i'm still just going off what i felt
after the fight so
follow-up to that how do you tap into
that when you don't have you're not
gonna have to smoke for people people
are gonna have to smoke for you that's
the thing about being the champion
exactly everybody looks at you there's
kids you've never heard of looking at
you like i'm gonna take that
[ __ ] out how do you find that
spark
like you said
like this this is one thing i really
enjoyed when i watched the last dance
um and i took that personally yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah even if nothing was
set yeah this is one thing that i have
made that up personally yeah like i've
done that before in my in my head
sometimes i'll kind of like it's
everything's a story we're telling
yourself what story are you telling
yourself yeah so each of each of my
fights has a narrative like example the
cost of fight right the narrative from
in my head was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] he
reminds me of all the [ __ ] [ __ ] i
used to pick on me in high school yeah
and he was like the quintessential jock
and the way he was acting as well fitted
the
fit of the um the you know the role so i
was just kind of like
[ __ ] this guy i'm gonna take him i'm
gonna take him out and the first
whitaker fight the way he was you know
like he was getting real cheeky and
smirky like that he was like that cool
at the i remember at the the press
conference before the fight
um he were in melbourne in his backyard
and it was like that that kid just like
talking [ __ ] and had us posse the whole
crowd kind of like huh hamming it up and
all that kind of [ __ ] yeah and i was
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's too comfy exactly too comfy
this time he was quite humble and just
humble and respectful about because i
whipped his ass so he had nothing to say
so
yeah um for me it's something i have to
go back and just look at within myself
and i
i think i have an idea of how to get it
done yeah yeah i don't want to give too
i wonder if you're at the stage your
career where you have to start building
up your opponents
i kind of do i've done that already i've
done that with jared i've done that with
darren till i've done that with a few
other guys just to kind of like you know
show because they're dangerous dudes but
a lot of them
i'm i'm i feel like like i said i'm
going to run to the same problem silva
ran into where it's like you know people
are just going to be scared to go after
you because they know what happens if
they go after yeah you know in the in
the third no in the fourth round i was
like we expected him to come crazy
because even his coaches apparently i
haven't watched the fight but they were
saying you're losing you need to like
step it up yeah so i don't know how the
[ __ ] he thought he won if his coaches
were saying you're losing this fight
don't worry about that yeah
i guess when i was like inventory
slipped the same one caused the hat
remember like uh you'd see this in
boxing matches sometimes you see an mma
as well like where you go to one of your
potential future opponents matches and
you sit in a front row yeah i used to
see that i'd be like oh they just really
love boxing and then i start to realize
no this is promo yeah this is building
the stakes and i'm looking at the ufc
roster and usually does a great job of
promoting fighters don't get me wrong
and especially if there's a fighter like
you and there's other guys like connor
who know how to promote themselves so
that's just pouring [ __ ] gas on the
flame but we're in a situation where
you're by far the most like famous and
dominant person in division yeah so it's
like are you gonna actually have to
start building up
the other guys in the division so that
there's more anticipation when you fight
them i think so because um like people
kind of know now even with this fight
with the same thing with the victoria
fight people already know like okay he
already beat him before yeah so he's
gonna do it again the cost of fight was
crazy because like people were like i
said he looks like that quintessential
that's great you know what i mean the
way he looks he looks like a hollywood
dude muscles and all that kind of stuff
so i'm like the skinny boy is going to
the skinny clown i love that you call
yourself the skinny kid i am 200
yeah there's one big juiced up brazilian
guy that makes you look skinny yeah and
i was like i bet watch this yeah and
that's how i felt that's uh so um i
tapped
and this is one thing i like i haven't
even
you know like sometimes i've been called
to the jungle in my in my time to like
go partake in plant medicines but i'm
like you know what
what if i get there and i like actualize
what what i'm trying to do and realize
where my faults are and my childhood
traumas and i'll pack a lot of [ __ ] what
if i then lose that edge it's kind of
like a numb if you guys seen avatar yeah
prince zuko when he finally became
friends with aang he couldn't fire bend
anymore he's like what the [ __ ] i can't
fire bend and it's because he didn't
have that drive lost the fire yeah he
lost the fire i agree with you i don't
want to fix this [ __ ] yet yeah so for me
i'm kind of like no i like being petty
no if
how could i possibly do that without
anger and hatred for all who oppose me
but for a fighter it makes sense you
gotta you're out there fighting for your
life you have to tap into that [ __ ]
primal thing exactly that's like caveman
[ __ ] we gotta live so i see for you that
is a thing that i'm like yo that's for
i want you to be out of mma quickly as
my boo i worry about your health thank
you baby and then you do all that [ __ ]
and then we flourish as a couple exactly
yeah you know a couple goals
by the way
you know yeah
he's trying to step forward he's trying
to i know right on my bro relax roll the
tape roll the tape into my eyes
married all that i understand though
you know easy when you done
[Applause]